History to me is not necessarily
about remembering the dates.
It's more about experiencing that
history while I'm learning the language.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here
again, uh, talking about languages
of course, and today I'm going to
talk about languages and history.
Uh, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on Spotify or
at least any other, um, podcast
service, please leave a review.
Why history?
Why do I want to talk about history?
Because history fascinates me.
And I think, you know, I realize that
people watch my videos either because
they're working on improving their English
or because they find them, you know,
my videos, in some way motivating and
encouraging and therefore encourages them
to continue with learning languages, which
in turn motivates me to make more videos.
And so I was thinking the
other day, you know, what
motivates me to learn languages?
So it started with a professor, as
I've said before, that I had at McGill
university, because we had French
at school, I wasn't very interested.
Uh, there were, you know, in a city
of 3 million people in those days in
Montreal, and there were 2 million French
speakers and 1 million English speakers.
I could have gone out and found people to
talk to if I wanted to, uh, I wasn't very
motivated until this professer, we had
this course, French civilization, and we
had this tremendous book and, you know,
between, uh, you know, Moliere and...
Voltaire and, and reading all these,
uh, bits and pieces of what, some of
the thinkers among thing and others, or
even seeing, uh, you know, the famous
painters like David and Watteau and all
of this it for whatever reason it turned
my crank and maybe it was the professor.
But it was largely a matter of history.
I suddenly became conscious of this,
this French civilization, which
like all civilizations went back
in history, but I became interested
specifically in French civilization.
Not that it is any more fascinating
or more valuable than any other
civilization, but it has its charm.
Its works of art.
Its, its architecture, its
literature, its history.
And I can still remember when I first
arrived in Paris, when I had hitchhiked
across the ocean on a, on a small German
tramp steamer and hitchhiked into Paris.
And I saw the Arc de Triomphe and I
said, I was just beside myself because
this is this history that I had become
so, uh, you know, interested in.
Um, and so that was...
and then I went to France and I
studied for three years and then
the next language was Chinses.
And I can remember when I got
into Chinese, what fascinated
me again was history.
Uh, I remember, of course, when we
first start out, we have to read things
that are relatively uninteresting, and
I've mentioned that we have to deal
with relatively uninteresting content
uh, with a lot of repetition, but
once we're able to start climbing
our way out of that, and we go
after things of interest, to me
it's history that I go after.
And so with Chinese, it
struck me as so romantic.
The idea that this ancient civilization
of China had all of a sudden come into
contact with the West, with different
ways of thinking, with science,
with different political systems
and how did they cope with that?
And so for me, some of the literature
and the history of the sort of first
half of the 20th century in China
was, was absolutely fascinating.
And I devoured material on that
subject, unfortunately, in Chinese
to read about ancient history very
often is more in sort of literary
Chinese and there is just a limitless,
limitless number of names to remember.
And I found that while, you know, it was
fascinating to conjure up the Tang dynasty
and how they lived and so forth or other
dynasties, the Han and the Shang, but
the portion of history that fascinated
me wasthe early part of the 20th century.
So that was Chinese.
When I came to Japan, I've mentioned
before I listened over and over to the
history of the Showa Era, which was
produced by NHK, which had the real voices
of the real people in radio programs and
elsewhere or radio announcers describing
events during the Showa Era, which
began...and again, I forget, you know, I
love history, but I forget it as fast as
I learn it but it was some time in the
twenties up until the second world war.
And then after the second world
war, um, yeah, the Showa Era...
I can't remember.
It doesn't matter.
History to me is not necessarily
about remembering the dates.
It's more about experiencing that
history while I'm learning the language.
So through the language, I'm getting
a flavor of the country, which then
influences my perspective on the country.
So that was true of, uh, of Japanese.
And I can recollect, recollect
listening to history, history of Poland.
As soon as I got through the mini
stories I found on, uh, publio.pl I
think it is, um, a book where I could
get both the audio book and the ebook.
And so I could read it on
LingQ and I could listen to it.
History of Poland, history of Ukraine,
history of Russia, uh, even certain
novels, like every Italian person I've
ever met say tells me that they find I
promessi sposi by Mazzoni very boring
cause they have to read it in school.
But for me it conjures up
17th century, I believe it is,
uh, you know, Northern Italy.
And so again, it's
history and to me, it's...
I, I remember jogging, uh,
listening to it, I promessi sposi,
and I listened to a lot of it.
Wonderful rendition by, uh , il
narratore which is a great site for
people who are learning Italian.
I mean every  language,
when I was looking...
and Greek the same way.
I found a podcast where they
talked about how the, the, uh,
Parthenon was built stone by stone.
And that was very difficult for me
because I didn't have the words,
but at least it was interesting.
And so I, and, and even now, you
know, it's, it's so fascinating.
Like, I, I stopped listening to,
or at least learning Korean because
there was a lack of content at my
level, but, sort of interesting...
there was interesting
content it was too difficult.
Htere was content that I could
understand that was uninteresting.
Uh, but lo and behold, my wife has
started watching these historical
dramas, Korean historical dramas.
And so that just gets me keen again.
So there's this one called the, The
Crowned Clown, which is like most
of these historical dramas, not very
believable, but still fascinating.
And of course it presents the costumes
and, and in that it's, it's, it's
that period where the Manchus who are
described there as being the late Jin,
because the Jin dynasty invaded the
Song, China, a Chinese dynasty back
in the, I guess the 12th century.
And this is the same Manchu people.
Uh, and they're once again, go
invade China and they invade Korea
and they then become, they start
calling themselves the Manchu and
they call themselves the Qing Dynasty.
But the interesting thing there, again,
So I look up on Wikipedia and you see
pictures of the sort of, uh, Ningjiasu
or Ningjiasu however he's pronounced, who
is the leader of the Jin, later Jin and
eventually, uh, which are known in English
as Jurchen or, uh, anyway, so he dresses
like it's all Chinese, culturally Chinese,
and yet the sort of scrolls behind him
are written in this vertical script.
Then when I look it up, it's the Mongol
Manchu script, which is an adaptation
of the  Uyghur script, which is in turn
an adaptation of the Sogdian script.
The Sogdians are, are an Iranian speaking
people who controlled the silk road.
Uh, and that in turn has its origins in
the Middle East, uh, you know, Aramaic
or I don't know, Syriac or Phoenicia,
and there's that it's all connected.
And once you begin, once you
start to realize, after a while
is all history is connected.
So we tend to, you know, the major
countries in the world, they did all
the history plus our own country.
But of course, you know, the
Manchus had their history, the
Mongol's have their history.
Uh, they connect through Central Asia to
Central Asia, which a thousand years ago
was a major center of, of world cultures.
Uh, connecting the Arab world with
the Indian world, with the Persian
world, with the Chinese world,
uh, Persians had a major influence
as did Arabs in the Tang dynasty.
There were many Persian and Arab
traders and, and literary people and
artists in, uh, I guess it was...
I can't remember.
So all of this stuff is connected.
So when I learn Persian now, of course
I, um, I'm just loving because a
lot of the historical stuff is too
difficult, but again, uh, Sahra has
created these 26 episodes of Iranian
history in easier language for me.
And so I listen to that and read that.
And, and that course, you know,
stimulates me to go off and read
about the history of Persia elsewhere.
So I just want to pass that along.
I mean, I could go on, I'm
trying to think of other...
like Ukrainian, again, to understand
Ukraine, you have to read Ukrainian
history and you have to read Ukrainian
history written by Ukrainians.
So if you're going to do that, then
may as well read it in Ukrainian and
may as well listen to the audio book
in Ukrainian, which I have done.
And so that gives you a perspective
on Ukraine, which is different from
a perspective on Ukrainian history
written by someone from Poland because
they dominated Ukraine for hundreds of
years, or written by someone from Russia.
Russia also dominated portions
of Ukraine for many years.
And so when you get the history of
the people spoken by the people in
their language and you can access it
and their history and their culture
and their various, uh, cultural
creations throughout their history,
that motivates me to learn a language.
It's not simply the fact that I
might be able to speak to someone.
Of course, I want to speak to someone,
but the motivation for me in these
languages is largely history and,
uh, watching that Netflix video the
other day has gotten me motivated
again to go and brush up my Korean.
We'll see what happens.
All these competing, uh, you know,
attractive languages to learn.
Anyway, I just wanted
to share that with you.
Uh, thank you for listening and
remember to get a, to, to, to
achieve your goals and language
learning, you have to be motivated.
You have to find things that motivate you.
Uh, and you have to read and listen
on those subjects of interest and I'll
leave a few videos that relate to that.
Thanks for listening.
Bye for now.